i won an Oscar I didn't win an Oscar you
later then cover with another but I'm
very very proud of them and I'm very
very proud of the film with our best
picture and you know that song
crystallizes how I feel about the film
how people are feeling about the film
and the message of the film so if that
was a great and it was so emotional it
was emotional because it's the
combination of a very long journey for
me getting to play dr. King is
definitely one of the most incredible
things I've I will probably ever do with
my life and you know I've traveled
around the world with that film now
nigeria Germany the UK all over America
and the effects having people is very
very real well I will enough of this
already